our first piece that we're going to  introduce is the king the king of course  is the most important piece in chess you  loses your king you lose the game how  does the King move the King can move one  square in any single direction the White  King on a one can move to the d2 square  the e2 square the f2 square the f1  square and the d1 square let's move our  King to d2 black similarly has the  choice where could he move his King to  any one square let's give him the move  King d7 as the Kings come up the board  we notice in this position with the  White King on e4 the black King on e6  that these three squares are mutually  attacked by both Kings neither King can  move to either of these squares if black  were to play King to d6 White's King  could not move to either d5 or even  you